Laforge: Okay, so,
welcome, everybody.
Uh, my pleasure
to have you here in this room.
And I'm going to speak
about Groovy,
the Groovy dynamic language
and Grails,
the web application framework.
and how they work
on Google App Engine.
I'm Guillaume Laforge.
So excuse me, perhaps I have
got a little French accent.
But I'm coming from France--
Paris.
I'm leading the Groovy Project.
I've been working
on that project
for already
quite a number of years.
I am also leading
the specification JSR-241
for standardizing
the Groovy language
inside the Java community
process.
I work for SpringSource,
so my "groovy" title
is head of Groovy Development.
I initiated the creation
of the Grails framework
back in 2005.
And I also coauthored this book
"Groovy In Action."
So if you want to make me rich
and buy the book,
on each copy I will get,
like, 50 cents
or something like that
because I just wrote
like a couple of chapters.
But you know,
you have to start small.
If I sell 1 billion
or 1 million at least,
maybe I'll get rich,
you know?
And I'm usually speaking
at various conferences
around the world.
So first of all, let's start
with a small question.
Who's familiar with Groovy?
Who's already used Groovy?
Okay, so that's
a fair number of you.
So the agenda,
I'm going to do a quick,
very quick overview
of what Groovy is,
its main features.
And I'll introduce you
to things like Groovlets,
our version of Groovy servlets,
Groovy templates.
And...a little hidden gem
I'll be mentioning as well,
but I didn't put it
in the agenda.
Then I will have
a look as well
at the Grails
web application framework
and how you can use Grails
to deploy applications
on Google App Engine.
Just to tell you
a bit of the story
behind the support of Groovy
on App Engine Java.
So, first of all,
I think it's a bit misleading
to say Google App Engine Java
because it's not just Java
the language, actually.
It's really Java
virtual machine basically.
It's more App Engine
on the Java Virtual Machine
because you can run
other languages.
It's not just about Java.
And back a few months ago,
thanks to my good friend
Dick Wall,
we got in touch
with the Java team,
the Google App Engine
Java team,
and we worked together
so that we could ensure
that Groovy would be
a first-class citizen language
for Google App Engine.
And let me thank
especially Toby
from the App Engine Java team
who really helped us,
greatly ensuring
that Groovy would run well
on that environment.
Okay, so let's start
more concretely.
So, a few words about Groovy.
So Groovy's a dynamic language
for the Java Virtual Machine.
Dynamic language
in the sense that
it's not a statically
typed language.
So it supports typing,
typing information,
so you can say string name
so it's not just loosely typed.
In that sense, it's not dynamic
because of typing
but dynamic because of
the way it behaves.
And there's a, what we call,
a Meta Object Protocol
which is the run-time behavior
of your types and classes.
And you can change the behavior
at run-time
of, uh...let's say you've got
a class, a string class,
and you can change
the behavior of strings
because you have access
to that run-time
Meta Object Protocol.
And it's a language
which combines
down directly to bicode,
so you can put, you know,
everything--
all those .class files
in a jar
and put that
in your class path.
It becomes kind
of an implementation detail
if you're using Groovy
or Java.
Also the nice aspect
of Groovy
is that it's been designed
to be totally, seamlessly
integrable with Java.
So you could, for instance,
let's say you have
a Java interface.
You extend that--you implement
that interface in Groovy
and extend that class
in Java and vice-versa.
You exchange Groovy and Java
in that sentence,
and basically
it will just work.
Which is not always the case
with other alternative
languages, unfortunately.
Groovy is also,
I forgot to mention,
an open source project
hosted at Codehaus.
And one of the design goals
when we worked on Groovy
in the first place
was that we wanted Groovy
to be a language for Java
developers mainly.
Although it's not just
for Java developers, obviously.
But the idea is that
we wanted to have Groovy be
as close as possible to Java,
so we even took the Java 5
grammar and kind of evolved it
to make it
a little bit more Groovy--
sorry for the pun--
because we were
a bit frustrated with Java,
and there were many features
we liked in all the languages
and we wanted to bring
those features to Java.
So Groovy's kind of our own
version of Java.
And also the fact
it derives from Java 5,
we also support features
like annotations,
generics, static imports,
varargs and so on.
So it's pretty handy,
and it's one of those
rail languages,
alternative languages,
which allow you to interact
with, let's say,
JDO, JPA, JB3,
all those stuff with
annotations, for instance.
So it's a nice choice
if you want to use those things
and if you want to use
an alternative language.
And we borrowed several ideas
from other languages.
And it's a language
which is pretty easy to learn
for Java developers.
So, now a little overview
of existing features.
So it's fully object-oriented.
Even when you say "three."
The number three,
it's really an object,
so you can do three
to a string on whatever.
When I mention seamless
Java integration, for instance,
we've got a joint compiler
which allows you to compile
everything in one go,
so when you've got
secular references
between Groovy and Java,
it's totally a transparence.
We added closures, those...
loosely defined definition
of closures,
basically some reusable
assignable code blocks.
We've got properties,
so you don't need
to write those getters
and setters every time.
We have optional typing,
so you decide
whether you want to say
def name or string name.
That's up to you.
We've got some various
short notations,
for instance, for accessing
getters and so on.
And we provide handy wrappers
around existing APIs,
for instance Groovlets
and template engines
that we'll come to
in a few slides.
And the syntax,
although it derives from Java,
we evolved it so it's pretty
malleable and you can write--
and also because of
the metaprogramming facilities,
you can write domain-specific
languages with Groovy.
Groovy's quite a good candidate
for writing embedded
domain-specific languages.
Okay, perhaps before showing
anything else,
when I say--
So, where's my...
my console there.
I'm going to increase
the font size.
Can everybody read that
in the back of the room?
Yeah? Okay.
So, let's take a small,
you know,
stupid
HelloWorld Java program.
So here I'm using
one of the tools
which comes with
when you download Groovy
from groovy.codehaus.org.
We've got a swing console.
We've got a shell as well.
There's a Groovy C compiler,
a Groovy interpreter.
So there are many tools
which comes with Groovy.
And to make you
a bit more familiar
for those who don't know Groovy
very much yet,
basically this is
a valid Java program
but I can actually run it.
It's also a valid
Groovy program.
But as you learn more and more
about Groovy,
you can make that Groovy--
Java program
more idiomatic Groovy.
So for instance,
you can remove things like
those boring
and ugly semicolons.
Okay.
And if I execute that,
it's still going to print
Hello Groovy.
What could I do?
By default,
we chose to make classes
and methods public
so you don't need
to repeat and specify public
all the time.
It can say
public string greet.
And it's still going to print
Hello Groovy when I run it.
Yeah, so I mentioned the fact
that we support properties.
So if you just say
instead of specifying
a visibility modifier,
if you just say String name,
you can even completely remove
the getter and the setter.
And the Ruby C compiler
is going to generate
a getter and a setter for you.
So if I run that again,
it's going to print Hello World.
We support what is probably
the sexiest feature
of the language.
We support
what we call G-strings.
So this is interpolated strings,
basically.
So instead of doing the usual
string + variable + string,
et cetera,
you can just say
return "Hello name."
It's going to refer
the $(name)
will be replaced with
the value of the name property
when the string
is going to be evaluated.
We cancel, for instance,
for the latest statement
of your methods
returning something.
You can even omit
the written key word.
So you can say just
Hello Groovy.
I'm just going to
say Hello Groovy.
What else?
Yeah, back on properties,
we also allow you
to use that shortcut notation
so you can say
.name = "Groovy"
And it prints Hello Groovy.
We can use named arguments
in the constructor.
Although there's no constructor
looking like that,
you can say "Groovy."
And what it's going to do,
it's going to create
instant shift Hello World
with the default constructor
and then call the setter
set name afterwards.
So it's a nice way
of initializing instances.
We've got some other shortcuts
like println.
You can also omit parentheses.
So I mentioned you can choose
to not type your variables
or your method parameters
and such.
It can say helloWorld.
And because Groovy's also
a scripting language,
you can remove that main method
and you can put some statements
outside of the class body,
and it's actually
becoming a script.
And, well,
now you've got something
which looks a bit more
idiomatic Groovy.
So progressively as you learn
more of Groovy,
you get some shorter samples,
some classes
which are way shorter.
And if you want to play
also with Groovy
without installing it
on your computer,
there's a Groovy web console,
which is actually
a Google App Engine,
a Google App Engine application.
So we can say, you know,
Hello Google IO.
or something like that,
and you can execute that
in the tile.
So if I execute....
okay, it's going to print
Hello Google IO.
You can see result,
the output, stacktraces...
if you've got stacktraces.
Okay.
So, back to the slides.
So since Groovy is a language
which is supported
on Google App Engine,
you can write a normal servlet.
But with all the tricks
we've learned,
you can do things like remove
the public key word.
You can...well,
you can remove the semicolons.
Since the response,
you've got
a set contentType method.
You can use that
shortcut notation--
resp.getcontentType=something.
And same for get writer.
You can just say it.
resp.writer.println
"Hello World!"
and it's going to print
something.
So if I have a look
at the--oops, sorry.
If I have a look at, um...
I put that there.
No, it's not the window
I wanted to see.
Where is it?
[humming]
Okay, open docs.
Yep, that's it.
So, if you look at basically
what it looks like,
well, this was my Hello World
program.
So I go to a small
more or less empty project
with some sources I wrote.
I'm going to open that
into TextMate for instance.
I even wrote a small Groovy
script to call end task
for doing things like
compilation and such.
And here's my Hello servlet,
the one you saw in the--oops--
in the slides.
So it's pretty much the same,
and this I made.
Yeah, I did a little additional
thing there
where you can see
I print that string
and inside, actually--
it's actually a G-string.
And I can use
a shell object from Groovy
to evaluate some expression.
So I can just show you
how it returned some results.
And then I've got
my App Engine file.
I've got my Groovy jar.
And in my web.xml
I've defined my servlet there,
defined also servlet mapping,
and to run that...
I think I can increase
the font size as well.
Okay, is it readable?
Okay, cool.
Okay, so we're there and
I'm going to that directory.
And if I run that locally
with the local App Engine
and I go back there,
and so it's I think the mapping.
It's...no, or...
yeah, it's help.
So you see it's really
a dumb servlet.
And the Groovy shell
evaluated the expression.
That's great, so nothing
really complicated.
But if you look back
at this example just there,
basically in Java
you always have
that kind of boiler-plate
technical code
where you have to
define a class,
you have to define methods,
and so on.
And although what you really
just wanted to show
was you wanted to print
Hello Google App Engine
and to print some value there.
So what if we were able
to just do that println
Hello Google app engine
and println somebody there?
Actually,
that's what Groovlets--
Oh, the slides are there.
That's what Groovlets
are for.
And basically Groovlets
lets you just write
what matters the most basically,
just println something.
And we also got
some interesting feature
which is called
the markup builder.
With Groovy, we support
the builder pattern somehow
at the syntax level.
And that's that concept
that we're going to use.
So for instance,
if I go back to my console...
which is just there.
If I import
groovy.xml.MarkupBuilder
and I def mkp =
new MarkupBuilder.
And then I can do mkp.html,
and let's say body.
And inside the body
I'm going to put some
paragraph "Hello,"
and it's going
to create some HTML.
And basically what you see here
is just a method call
which takes
a closure as parameter.
And inside that closure
you see another method call
which is delegated
to the markup builder
which takes another closure,
and inside that closure--
so you see the nesting
of the note HTML body p.
At the syntax level--
[stammers]
And with nice
curly braces around
and you say p "Hello"
and it's going to print p Hello.
So if you use something
like that in a script,
you could output some HTML
pretty easily.
And that's what we're doing.
So with this
second example there...
I'm going to use TextMate again.
So instead of the servlet class
that you saw earlier,
so I'm going to do basically
the same since.
So it's just a script,
And I can use this nice
markup builder.
I'm going to put that
a bit bigger.
Okay, so you can use such
a structure in your script.
And you can then run that.
Okay, kind of close this one.
You can then run that.
Ah...where is it?
2-groovlet
dev_appserver war/
and guess what
it's going to show you...
So what's the name of that?
Where is it?
I'm lost.
Yeah, so it's called Hello,
so I have to say hello.groovy.
And all the...Hello...
so all the Groovy files
are actually situated
in WEB-INF
and you can put them under
Groovy or elsewhere.
And the servlet there,
so I defined a Groovy servlet
and mapping to coach
all the star.groovy URLs
and redirect that
to this little groovlet.
So you don't have
all the usual boiler-plate code
of defining a class,
some methods and so on.
But you can use that.
Okay, back to the slides.
So we can use
the markup builder,
and basically you just need
to reference
the GroovyServlet
and find the URL mapping.
And we also have another
feature in Groovy
which is we've got built-in
template engines, basically.
So if you've got a string
which looks like that
and where you can use
like in G-strings
this $ (month) notation,
or you can use like in JSB's
this < and % symbol.
Or you can also use this
to insert some value.
This is just a block of code
that's going to be interleaved
in the string,
so you can print to that string
or you can directly insert
some value.
And then you can also pass
some binding,
some variables
inside that template.
So you create
your TemplateEngine.
You create the template,
the text,
and you make--
you replace, actually,
all those variables
on placeholders and such
with the variables
from the binding,
and then it's going to
create a template,
and then you can output that.
So we created
the Groovlet concept,
and thanks to
the Groovy templates,
we also created
a spatial template
which takes templates as inputs.
So instead of using
the markup builder,
you can define some HTML
and use things like
$(message) and so on.
And you can have--
so if I show you that in--
whoops--
my small example.
Again...so I stop this one.
I go in templates and...
I'm going to open that...
in TextMate again...
and that's basically
the same thing, so...
I defined the...
I defined as in my slide
the TemplateServlet,
and I kept also
the GroovyServlet from earlier.
Here you can still use
the groovlet,
but I defined this extension.
So if you look on that,
I did this *.gtpl,
so all these files
are going to be...
all these URLs are going to be
sent to the TemplateServlet.
And you can look at
my index GTPL
and, for instance,
just like, well...
more or less like in JSPs
and such,
you can say $(new Date)
and it's going to replace
that placeholder with the date,
or you can use things like...
well, in Groovy, we added some
methods to things like numbers,
and we added a times method
on numbers
so that you can say
3.times.
And three times,
we are going to execute
the body of that closure.
And it means that we'll be
printing Hello World
in the output three times.
And something
which is interesting also
is that there are
some shortcut methods
for doing things like
includes, redirect, forward.
What else?
I think that's all.
So you can also do some
page composition, basically.
And in my other template there,
I've got a little div
and I can say tomorrow =
new Date() + 1.
And in Groovy, you can also do
operator loading,
so if you do new Date() + 1,
it's going to add one day
to the new date.
And if I...
if I run that,
so I'm changing again...
No, I'm already
at the right place, so...
[humming]
Yes.
dev_appserver war
Okay. And if
I go back there and...
so what was the index GTPL?
And okay, it's going to say
today is this date.
Three times,
I'm going to print Hello World,
and tomorrow
is Friday the 29TH.
And even with
the time zone difference,
because for me it's still
somehow midnight.
It just works.
Okay. So, uh...what else?
I think I've shown everything
for the template.
So also what's interesting
is that
usually Groovlets are probably
what you'd use for,
you know, controllers
and templates for your views.
So the best approach,
although I'm mixing
everything there,
but the best approach
usually is to have
your controllers as Groovlets
and then somewhere there
you can say forward--oops.
You can say something like
forward to my view, okay?
You can do things like that.
And you can also put things
in the request that...
so that you can pass
some values back to the view.
Okay, that's the basic idea.
Okay...
.save? No.
So this was the server template,
and there's something...
pretty new which is not
yet available on the Web.
But I'll put that soon online.
So all these things are provided
by Groovy out of the box
so you can use Groovy servlet,
can use Groovy templates
and so on.
So you just need basically
the Groovy jar
into your webbing INF/lib.
But we thought that we could
add some additional sugar
on top of the Groovy servlets
and the Groovy templates.
And Gaelyk...
so there's a little pun.
I tried to find a name with
a G--Google App Engine letters.
The acronym.
Oh! [laughs]
So basically,
it's just a very thin layer
on top of the Groovlets
and the servlet templates
plus some wrapper around
the Google App Engine
Java SDK APIS.
And for instance,
all those nice services
which are provided
by Google App Engine
like the image manipulation
like the user service,
like what else?
The URL fetcher...
all these handy services
are injected in Groovlets
and Groovy templates.
And we also started to add
some new additional methods
to simplify the use of the SDK
of the APIs
of Google App Engine, Java.
So another very small demo
of that...
which is...okay.
Just so I stop this server
and I go to...
Gaelyk.
And I'm going to open that
in TextMate again.
So...I created--
so I've gone over
to the old template there
where, actually--so all the
services are injected directly.
So you don't
have to reference them
or pass them in any way.
But basically,
just do datastoreService
or memcacheService, and you
can access those services.
So here I'm just going to print
the two string of these services
and I'll show you the...
category sample afterwards.
Now I'm going to show you
just that right now.
So what we wanted to do is...
so if you look on the low-level
datastore API...
when you use--
I can't even show you
like the...the API...
the Java doc directly.
So if you look at
the datastore--
Oh, interesting.
Firefox, a bug perhaps.
If you look at...
where it is--
it is there--
the entity--
It keeps on doing that.
That's not very nice.
So if you look at the entity,
the low-level API
and the entity class
in particular,
you've got methods like...
getProperty or setProperty.
But for instance,
if your entity represents
a concept like a person,
you'd like to be able to say
a person.name
or a person.age,
but if you use
the low-level API,
you'll have to say
the new entity,
you define the kind,
like new Entity("person")
And then my entity.setProperty
name, some value.
But with Groovy, the fact
that it's a dynamic language
we can use a shorter notation,
and we somehow decorated
some of the classes
of the Java SDK
so as to add some syntax
sugar on top of that.
So instead of the not very
friendly Java version,
you can do something like that.
For instance, you define
a new entity the same way.
But you can say use either
the subscript notation.
So the...with, you know,
those square brackets.
So you can say entity
["name"] = something.
Or you can also use
this other syntax,
which is the normal getter,
shortcut notation.
And you can access it.
So I'm using again
the markup builder
for printing something...
and what other methods
we added.
For instance, to on entity
we added a delete method
because it's on
the datastore service.
It's got a delete method,
but the delete method
is not on the entity.
So we added a delete method,
a save method.
And some of the other
nice little things we did--
you can say...
we created a withTransaction
method
which takes a closure
as parameter.
And inside that closure,
all the operations are going
to be done in that transaction.
So there are getProperty...
no, it's on the datastore.
Datastore Service
where you've got methods
like get...
to get an NTT
from the datastore,
you usually get by its key
or you can pass a transaction,
getTransaction
and all the keys.
So we wanted to simplify a bit
those...
those operations
to make things a bit nicer,
a bit Groovier.
And another example
of the little things we did...
so if you look
at the mailService API,
you have to create
a new mailService.message class
called the getters and setters--
actually, the setters.
So you say mailmessage.set to,
.set sender, et cetera.
And we wanted to use
named arguments,
which are supported in Groovy
so that you could use
that syntax
to easily write an email
to someone
using the mailService API.
So I can run
this little example.
Nothing earth-shattering.
Okay. Oh, I'm already
in the right place,
dev_appserver war/
And, okay,
if I go back there...
so I think it's still
index GTPL, if I'm not wrong.
Basically you can see that...
we printed the two strings
of all the injected services.
Oh, yeah, there's also a user
variable which is injected.
So if there's a user
currently logged in,
you're going to see
that user there.
And then the various operations
I showed you
like creating a new entity,
starting a transaction,
and so on.
And sending an email.
Okay. So now that we
talked about...
so I'm going to stop the server
before I forget.
And I'm going to speak now
about Grails.
Okay. So Gaelyk
is going to be available
on gaelyk.appsupport.com.
I even put the URL
because I have not deployed
anything there.
But it's really something
completely new,
so it's still pretty...
there's not much yet available
apart from what I've shown you.
But it's going to be there
sometime soon.
[applause]
Thank you.
So now...
so we worked with the Google
App Engine Java team
to make Groovy
a first-class citizen
in terms of language supported
on App Engine Java.
But we also worked
pretty recently
on the support of Grails,
the web application framework,
which is actually
a small, simple equation.
Grails is Groovy for writing
everything like controllers,
domain classes, et cetera.
It's also Spring,
which everything is based
on top of Spring.
And if you use it--
if you use it
outside of App Engine, usually,
you use Hibernate
for the persistence.
So it's a mix of these things.
And not just that.
It's also a mix of...
it's built on top of
really rock-solid
and proven open source bricks,
so Spring, and Spring MVC,
Spring WebFlow.
You can do page composition
with SiteMesh.
You can have Quartz jobs.
And it comes bundled with
the Jetty servlet container
and an in-memory
relational database, HSQLDB.
And we put a small O-R-M layer
on top of Hibernate
to simplify things...
in a nice way.
It provide its own
command line tools
so it can say Grails,
run app,
Grails, create domain class,
et cetera.
So this is our command line
interface,
and it's actually...
you can call it so some
build commands,
such as Grails war,
so it creates your war,
and you can put that war
on any solid container
very easily.
And we took
some great inspiration
from other frameworks like
Ruby on Rails, for instance.
So we forward certain paradigms,
certain principles like
convention of a configuration.
So instead of--well, when you're
writing a Java application,
you usually have to choose
all the bricks you want to,
mix together, define,
configure together, et cetera,
so you usually waste
a bit of time.
Grails comes bundled
with those bricks preconfigured.
Usually you have more time
to focus on what matters,
the business concepts
and so on,
rather than
a boring configuration.
And we also provide
features like scaffolding
to help you get started
and have some, you know,
simple CRUD UIs
on top of your domain classes.
There's a nice extensible
plugin system,
so you can extend
and expend Grails
to provide different
view layers,
different integrations
with all their external APIs
or, for instance,
using security APIs
or using JMS, etcetera.
So you can use plugins
on that kind of stuff.
And you can have
pretty modular pages
because you can use SiteMesh
for page composition.
You can use taglibs for--
if you've got some UI widgets
that you want to reuse
across your obligation,
you can create taglibs
very easily,
way more easily
than with JSP taglibs.
We've got templates,
and so on.
And this is
the overall big picture.
So Grails's on top of all these
nice open source bricks,
and Groovy on the side
for writing domain classes
and so on.
And if you look at,
when you create a new project--
actually, I think I'm going
to show you that right after...
Well, the fact it comes--
it follows certain conventions
and the project structure
or the project layout
is also part of
the conventions.
So we follow
the MVC principles.
So you've got controllers,
your domain classes
are your model.
You can put the views
in the views directory,
and so on.
You can put libraries,
additional libraries.
You can put scripts
for the build system,
additional sources,
your test classes, et cetera.
And all your JavaScript
or images, CSS.
You can put them
in the web-app and directory.
So that's the Global
Project structure.
And since Grails
provides a plugin system
so as to make Grails
extensible,
there are tons of fixes
in plugins,
well over 100.
I think it's like 130
or something like that.
So if you don't like using--
I haven't shown you that yet,
but the--we use GSPs,
Groovy Server Pages,
which is kind of like the Groovy
templates you saw earlier.
But if you prefer using GWT
for your view layer
or Flex or any Ajax toolkit
or this iPhone view layer,
or if you want to use JMS
for communication
or adding search capabilities,
your Grails application
using JSecurity
or Spring security
you can choose the right
plugin for your needs.
And there are many plugins
for your needs.
And very recently,
we created a specific
Google App Engine plugin.
So that you are able
to quickly create applications
which are going to work
on Google App Engine
and provide some additional
command-line options
for deploying your application,
running your application locally
with the local JT container
and so on.
So here are the steps
we're going to follow,
and I'm going to show you
just that...
if I go back to
my console there.
So I'm going to create
grails create app.
I'm going to create...
I'm going to create
a new application...
demo2,
because I created demo1.
Let's create a second demo.
So I install Grails
on my machine...
in some place on my machine,
and I just created a Grails
home environment variable.
I added Grails home bin
in my path
And then I can use
all the Grails commands.
So I created an application,
a blank application,
so you see there the new
directory that it created.
So I can go to demo2
cd in the directory.
And if you look at
what's available...
so I've got basically
the structure you saw earlier
with...I can put my controllers,
my domain classes there.
So this is taglibs, et cetera.
So this is currently
just an empty application,
but you can already run it.
So you don't have
to configure anything to wire.
Spring Hibernates
out of the box.
You've got
a running application.
So if I just run
that application...
Running Grails application...
it takes a few seconds
to start up on my machine.
Okay, so if I go
to demo2 here,
demo2...
it created a small,
empty Grail application,
so you've got a welcome string.
Screen, not string.
But that's all you have
right now.
Okay, so I go back there.
I'm stopping there.
I'm going to...
first of all,
since we're not going to use
a relational database,
I'm going to uninstall
the hibernate plugin.
Then I'm going to install...
the app engine plugin.
And it's going to ask me
a little question...
in a second.
Okay, so it's downloading.
Blah, blah, blah.
DO you want to use JPA
or JDO for persistence?
So we don't use
the low-level API,
but we can use either JPA
or JDO,
so let's say...
let's say JPA.
Why not?
Okay, so I created...
I installed
the App Engine plugin.
And now I'm going to create
a domain class
called Book.
Why not?
So what the plugin does also,
we've got some templates
for generating things like
the views, the controllers
for the scaffolded views.
And the plugin provides
new command-line options.
That also provides
some new templates
for creating, for instance,
the domain classes.
So if you look at my Book
domain classes here...
Okay.
So it created a Book classes
annotated with @Entity
Javax.persistence.
And you can see the ID there.
Grails provides
some nice constraints
so you can put some constraints
on your, you know, your fields.
So a Book...
basically a Book has got a title
and we've got an author, okay?
A very simple example.
And now what I can do is
grails generate all.
Not something I wanted to do.
Or in other words,
it's not going to work.
I have to use a package,
so I'm going to...
mkdir.
Because otherwise App Engine
doesn't like very much
if you don't put
your domain classes,
your JPA annotated classes
in the default package.
So I always forget that step.
So I have to forward
that step myself...
domain, let's say...
demo package.
I'm going to move my--
so I should have done that
right away.
Sorry for that.
[humming]
domain/demo.
And I'm going to edit
my Book class again
to add the package information.
Should have done that
firsthand too.
I don't need semicolons.
Can even remove that.
Okay, so I've got
a package demo.
If I didn't make a mistake,
now I'm going to generate...
generate...
all Book.
And it's going to create
some controller and some views
for this Book domain class...
using the new templates
providing by the Google App
Engine plugin for Grails.
Okay. Oh ho...
I made some mistakes, I guess.
Interesting.
No per system provided, um...
what's wrong there?
I don't know.
man: [indistinct]
Laforge: Sorry?
Laforge: Uh, yes,
looks like it's saved.
Views...it didn't
generate anything.
What could be wrong there?
man: [indistinct]
Laforge: Mm...
I don't see...anything.
Well, never mind.
I'll show you the one
which is running.
Must be something...stupid.
Okay, so back there...
So basically, you're right
at the exact same state there.
So I open that again.
So it should really be
the same thing.
I don't know why...
So my Book domain class
is there.
So that's exactly
what I had written,
if I'm not mistaken.
Package demo.
It created a controller here,
the Book controller.
So we've got methods like
index, list, show, delete--
all the usual CRUD operations.
And it's using the...
the--where is it?
For instance.
Yeah, here you can see
that we injected
Spring's transactionTemplate
or JPATemplate
and then you can call
JPATemplate
to execute some queries,
et cetera,
forwarding
all the CRUD operations.
And here we've got the view,
so it created...create GSP,
edit, list, and so on.
And you can see how,
for instance,
we've got taglibs for...
for creating some nice
tabular representation
of all the instances of Book.
And if I run that locally...
so the...
App Engine...
so I forget about the commands.
I never remember by heart.
Okay, and for plugin
App Engine...
App Engine run.
That's App Engine run
that I have to call.
App Engine...
so app engine run command
is added by the App Engine
plugin.
And if I run that,
I'm then able
to start my application...
using the JDO enhancer class
below the JPA implementation.
And then
in a couple of seconds,
it's going to be...running.
Yes.
Okay, I'm launching that.
In the usual web welcome string,
you can see the available
controller,
so for instance,
the BookController.
And, okay, it remembered
some entries.
Let's say...
Andres Almiray...
Griffen in Action.
And I can create new instances,
and you can see
there's a nice table
and you can see, you know,
all the books and so on.
I can edit again if I made
a typo or something.
I can update, I can delete.
So all the usual
CRUD applications--
operations are there.
So I don't think I configured
my App Engine HML properly.
But if I had done so,
I could just say
Grails App Engine
to deploy on App Engine.
So in just one single
simple command,
I can show you.
So I don't want to try
the connection,
just in case it doesn't work.
So basically,
some differences would be
some conventions
that Grails usually follows.
When you create
a Grails application,
it starts with a 1.0 version--
or 0.1, I always forget.
But on App Engine
you have to use integers,
so you can say
set-version 1.
Then you can package
your application
so that you can then use
app-engine deploy
to deploy on App Engine.
So I'm not going
to show you that,
because there's like
20 megabytes of jars
and it takes a while to download
on the first download--
on the first upload, sorry.
But what's nice
with App Engine
is that with the command,
afterwards
when you make changes,
it's just divs
that are sent through the wire.
So it's quite nice.
But trust me, you can use
just that command line,
and it's going to deploy
on App Engine.
Okay. So that was the demo.
Yeah, just before us
doing the little summary,
just to mention some little
sample applications
that are online.
For instance...
so I mentioned these--
where is it?
The web console
that I created,
Groovyconsole.appspot.com,
or just to show you
another little example
and why App Engine is...
quite neat.
I made a small mashup
of Google Maps,
the Flickr API
for returning pictures
and I also used the Google
geocoding service
so that if I put some...
let's say the Eiffel Tower
in Paris.
I do this...
it's going to center the map...
on Paris.
Takes a while.
Don't know why.
And...so it's--yeah.
The Eiffel Tower
is right there,
and it's going to show you
some pictures
of the Eiffel Tower,
some past searches from users.
And just to show you what's
so nice with Groovy itself,
for instance,
if you look at...
so where is it--there.
If you look at
this small application,
I'm going to show you
the codes.
Basically...
one of the nice things I like
particularly with Groovy
is for doing things
like accessing some URLs.
I define a URL, then I get
the input stream on that URL.
I can use the Groovy XML
facilities for parsing XML.
And although--well,
you don't have to use
the dumb API or anything.
You can just say
node.Response.Status.code
and it's going to fetch
the right node in your XML.
So in just very simple,
you know, expressions like that,
you can retrieve
the coordinates.
So this is the part where
I'm using the geocoding service
because I want to retrieve
the latitude and longitudes
of some special address.
Then I also call Flickr...
with some key words using--
in the address
so that I find pictures
which are related to that point.
And again, I'm using XML Slurper
to retrieve from the response
all the photos
that I'm creating,
a list of photos
defining URLs of these photos.
And then I'm using
the markup builder
to create the HTML view
that you saw.
So for instance,
I'm using the Ajax APIs
for loading Google Maps.
Then I've got a small form
and I also use the NTT,
put stuff in the datastore.
And basically in just--okay,
almost 90 lines of code,
you've got a small mashup
of three different services.
So it's pretty...
pretty funny.
Okay...
so to summar--everything--
so Groovy is also
a first-class citizen
on the Google App Engine.
So you can use Java, but you
can use all the languages
like Groovy, for instance.
There are many
shortcuts notations
which allow you, for instance,
parsing XML
in a pretty neat way,
accessing the DOM and so on
very easily.
We provide servlets
and templates
for controllers and views.
And when it's going to be
officially released,
the small Gaelyk model
will allow you
to simplify even further
the development
of small applications
with role Groovy.
But if you want to build
some more complex--oops.
If you want to build
some more complex applications,
you'd obviously
better use Grails
because it really simplifies
and streamline
the development
of web applications.
And thanks to the App Engine
plugin,
it's pretty easy to deploy--
develop and deploy applications
on the App Engine clouds.
A few links.
So you'll find them on the
slides when you've got them.
On the SpringSource blog,
I wrote a small example,
a small tutorial
on developing Groovy web apps
for App Engine.
And my colleague,
Graeme Rocher,
the leader of
the Grails project,
also created
a nice Spring case study
that shows something like
the demo I showed earlier.
So I invite you
to look at that.
And the App Engine plugin,
that's where you can find it.
So thanks a lot
for your attention,
and I think we've got
just three minutes left
for some questions
and perhaps some answers.
So please use the mic
if you want to ask questions.
And also, don't forget
provide some feedback
and go to haveasec.com/IO
to provide feedback
on the presentations,
speakers, and so on.
Thanks.
[applause]
Thank you.
Yeah.
man: Can we run Groovy
on top of
the Dolphin Virtual Machine
on Android?
Laforge: So Groovy on Android?
man: Yeah.
Laforge: So far, we can't.
[chuckles]
But we've got
a Google-summer-of-code
student this year
who's going to work on
supporting Groovy in Android.
So hopefully--
fingers crossed--
you may be able to develop
Android Apps and...
using Groovy as language.
Thank you.
man: Hi. I saw that
you had mentioned
the Google Web Toolkit...
Laforge: Yep.
man: So--so far, all the apps
were developed here
just using either just
Groovy or Grails.
Where does the Google Web
Toolkit come in?
And right now,
the Google Web Toolkit
can only, as far as I know,
accepts Java.
So how can you use Groovy in...
Laforge: So the...so if you
install the GWT,
the G-W-T plugin.
So instead of using JSPs,
like, you know, those templates
that I showed you,
actually, you can use
normal G-W-T,
you know,
Java classes and so on,
for your view.
And we've got some hooks
so that you can call back
to the Grail services,
which are exposed as,
you know,
RPC servlets for GWT,
so you can interact,
have your nice UI in GWT
and talk to a back end service
built on Grails.
man: So there's no getting
away from Java, though.
Laforge: And obviously,
the GWT part is developed
with Java, not with Groovy.
man: Yeah. Okay.
Laforge: We need to develop
a kind of special compiler
which combines Groovy
into JavaScript,
but we've not done that yet.
man: Okay. Something
to wish for.
Laforge: Thanks.
man: Thank you.
Laforge: Any other question?
One last?
We've got 30 seconds.
You've got 28 seconds!
man: Is there any plans
for a plugin for Wave?
The Wave.
The robot part.
Laforge: Ah!
Not yet.
[laughs]
It's a bit too soon, but
that would be interesting, yes.
Okay, thanks again
for your attention.
[applause]